Why Michael Jackson's Skin Turned White as
He Got Older
Many scandals marred Michael Jackson’s personal
life, overshadowing his otherwise remarkable
musical career.
One such scandal was the obvious change in
his appearance, especially his skin color,
which started from the mid-eighties to slowly
but surely turn from dark to white.
By the mid-nineties when Jackson released
his album History (1995), it was more than
obvious even to his most dedicated fans that
the man of Thriller (1982) looked nothing
like the man who had recently married Elvis
Presley’s daughter, Lisa Marie.
By this time, Michael Jackson was milky white;
a skin-color transition that started almost
a decade earlier was more or less complete.
So what happened?
According to his family and Jackson himself,
the “King of Pop” had vitiligo, a condition
that causes depigmentation of parts of the
skin, which usually results in white spots
on the patient’s body; these are even more
noticeable if the person has a dark complexion
as in Jackson’s case.
The 1 in 250 or so people who have this condition
typically first start seeing signs of it beginning
between 10 and 30 years old.
Approximately 30% of the people who have it
also have it run in their family, which is
true of Jackson.
In addition to this skin disorder, Jackson
also reportedly suffered from systemic lupus
erythematosus, which besides potentially being
a very serious condition can also cause loss
of skin pigmentation.
When the controversy about his changing skin
color hit its zenith, Jackson spoke openly
about his vitiligo for the first time in an
interview he gave to Oprah in 1993.
He said among other things,
It is something I cannot help.
When people make up stories that I don’t
want to be who I am, it hurts me.
It’s a problem for me.
I can’t control it.
But what about all the millions of people
who sit in the sun to become darker, to become
other than what they are.
Nobody says nothing about that.
VitiligoIn the days after, at Jackson’s
request his condition was publicly confirmed
by his dermatologist, Dr. Arnold Klein, who
also stated Jackson was first diagnosed with
the condition in 1984.
It was also confirmed that he had lupus erythematosus,
but that it was in remission.
Conspiracy theorists propose that there was
much more to it than this.
That in fact Jackson had no such disease and
that he, instead, systematically bleached
his skin using Benoquin cream and other medical
cocktails in his quest to look like a white
person.
The obvious and extensive cosmetic surgeries
he had on his eyebrows, eyelashes, lips, and
nose only served to enforce the theory that
he was simply purposefully tweaking his appearance
even more by bleaching his skin.
Vitiligo2So is there any truth to this?
Dr. Christopher Rogers, deputy medical examiner
at the Los Angeles Coroner’s Office and
the man who conducted Michael Jackson’s
autopsy, chimed in on this after performing
the autopsy on Jackson.
Dr. Rogers confirmed that Jackson indeed suffered
from vitiligo, most noticeably with patches
around his face, chest, abdomen, and arms.
So did he also bleach his skin?
According to dermatologist Dr. Hanish Babu,
Jackson did; this is sometimes a treatment
used for those with vitiligo.
When these white patches first started appearing,
you can see from certain of Jackson’s concert
footage that he was trying to mask them with
makeup matching his original skin color.
Once the patches became too numerous to easily
hide with makeup (and he supposedly became
tired of the extensive time needed to apply
the makeup every day), he switched strategies
and began the process of bleaching his skin,
supposedly under the care of his dermatologist
and using 20% monobenzyl ether of hydroquinone
(Benoquin Cream).
Much later, in June of 2009 after his death,
tubes of Benoquin and hydroquinone were found
in Jackson’s home.
As Dr. David Sawcer said, “some patients
with vitiligo get to the point where it makes
more sense to remove the brown bits because
so much of the skin is pale.”
Besides giving him a white complexion, this
also results in being prone to sun burns,
which is why in later years he often kept
himself nearly completely covered when outside
in the sun.
(See What Causes Sunburns and How Sunscreen
Prevents It)
In the end, only Jackson knew his true motivation
for ultimately choosing to bleach his skin,
whether as a treatment for his vitiligo to
even out his skin color as reported, or as
the conspiracy theorists claim, to further
change his appearance to more of a Caucasian
look, though one would think the latter would
be an odd move for the co-author of the line
(with Bill Bottrell), “It don’t matter
if you’re black
or white.”